ظهور علني لابنه الزعيم الكوري الشمالي
كيم جونغ اون مرتين خلال اسبوع واحد فقط
كان كثيرا باثاره تكهنات لبدايه تقديمها
للجمهور كخليفه محتمله لوالدها في حكم
البلاد الكشف عن شخصيه ابنه كيم جونغ اون
اثر اهتمام محلي لكوريا الشماليه اكثر
بكثير من الاخبار عن انطلاق الناجح لاقوى
صاروخ بالي استيعابر بالقرب
الحكوميه لم تكشف عن اسم الفتاه او عمرها
ووصفتها فقط بانها الطفله المفضله او
الغاليه على قلب والديها زعيم كوريا
الشماليه اذا شخصيه الاسبوع في صباح
العربيه جو اي هو الاسم الطفل الغاليه في
وسائل الاعلام الاجنبيه ابنه زعيم مملكه
الغموض كما يطلق عليها
غالبا ما اختفت النساء في حياه زعماء
كوريا الشماليه بسبب كثير من الخصوصيه
التي وصلت الى حد اخفاق حقائق حول عدد
ابنائهن او تواريخ بلادهن لكن مع زعيم
الحالي تسرب القليل او ما اراده ان يظهره
من حياته الشخصيه سنبدا بابنته محل الجدل
الحالي لؤي عام 2013 نقلت صحيفه الغامديا
عن اللاعب كره السله الامريكيه دنيا بعد
عودته من كوريا الشماليه ان زعيمها انجبت
طفله صغيره وكشف ان اسمها جو اي وصف كيم
حينها وصف بالاب الجيد هي عائلات جديده
ومنذ ذلك الوقت لم تظهر سوا في التاسعه
عشر من نوفمبر الجاري كما صور وكما في
صورها مع ابيها كنا يتحدثان مع المسؤولين
يتفقدان الصواريخ ويشاهدان اطلاق صاروخ
بالسي عابرت بعد اسبوع واحد فقط نشرت
وكاله الانباء المركزيه الرسميه مجموعه
اخرى من الصور لهما هذه المره ايضا لن
يذكر فيها عمر الف او اسمها ولكن وصفت
بانها الطفل الاحب او الاعز على قلب
الزعيم كيم جونغ اون
لقب الاول كسيد اولى في كوريا الشماليه
بعد ان كانت زوجه الزعيم تحمل لقب الرفيقه
تقاريره تؤكد انها واحده من المغنيات في
اوركسترا انهاسو ويشاري لان اعلان الزواج
لم يحدث الا بعد ان حرص المسؤولون على محو
ماضيها الترفيه من اقراص مدمجه وغيرها
معكم الان الى ثالث همم سيده في حياه
الرئيس الاخت ذات النفوذ الكبير كيم يونج
التي تتولد بارزه وتوجه تحديدات مهينه
للغريمه كوريا الجنوبيه وعندما انتشرت
شائعه و التكهنات في عام 2020 حول صحه
الزعيم الكوريه الشماليه باتيونذر لاخته
كينيون جونغ على انها نائبه محتمله لتولي
زعامه العائله والحفاظ على هذه السلاله
الى ان يصبح احد اطفال في سنن تاهله لتولي
زمام القياده